Chase what's up buddy ltrs yeah hey Rich
how's it going
um this is actually one of my first
times calling in so thanks for having me
all right your book the other night
great read
um I've also read like The Art of
Seduction a bunch of stuff by Mark
Manson
um 25 years old live in like the
southern us and really wanted to get
your thoughts on uh ltrs and if they
really kind of make sense for someone
that's 25
um and the reason I'm not sure in my
video I would love to share numbers
about income I hit all that stuff
um just to kind of give you an idea of
where I'm at and you know what I should
be looking for in this point in my life
um so you're 25 why are you asking about
a long-term relationship because some
general advice that I've always given is
if in your 20s you should be building
your life up setting the foundation for
yourself
LTR unless it's a real good compliments
your life should probably General
generally just be avoided you know for
the most part
yeah because like my whole thing is like
I used to live in New York City and uh
was very much so into one night stands
hookups very short term things and I did
that for you know like three or four
years
um I used to DJ up there and and with
that comes the status and so you get a
lot of attention doing that and don't
get me wrong I definitely had my fun
doing that
um my challenge with that is that it's
just
I don't know just got old and tiring for
me I don't really know how else to say
it um how much really had how much money
did you make last year uh so last year
just over six figures okay
this year I'll do uh summer between 125
and 150 in total comp
okay
um
so you're so you're off to Good Start is
that going to multiply so you can get
into seven figures in the next five to
ten years
um I could I work in Tech trade and so
if I did work for one of the big tech
companies I could see you know north of
400k total comp maybe it is 750 total
comp if I didn't go that route within
the next five to ten years
no children
um not necessarily a priority for me at
this point but are you open to children
in the future open to it yeah but
definitely not a priority so look I mean
if you want to start dealing with
long-term relationships it sounds like
you've had some short terms so you
should have your head around what women
typically respond to you've read some
good books uh you've obviously followed
my channel so that's a good choice have
you read my book yep yep I actually just
finished it the other day cool
um by the way do me a solid if you got
value out of the book I'm saying this to
everybody please go to Amazon and leave
a review and just let guys know what you
got out of it
um
you don't need anybody's permission to
get into a long-term relationship with a
woman the thing that you have to do
though is that if you're going to invite
a woman into your life on a long-term
basis you're going to introduce her to
family and you're going to do things
with her and hang out and take vacations
and stuff like that you want to make
sure she's a good compliment to your
life so it's not that much different
from dating or doing anything short term
it's just okay now you're going to be
open to the idea of
um you know is this the kind of chick
that can take care of me if I get sick
is this the kind of chick that I can
um you know when she's coming over I've
had a busy day I'm chasing Excellence
putting a dent universe and my dry
cleaning needs to get picked up and I
can get her to grab it for me on the way
over sort of thing is this the kind of
woman that's going to add some value to
my life and be a compliment to to it
sort of thing and if kids are something
that you might look at later on down the
road are you going to
um you know turn it into mother stock
sort of stuff so it's just vetting it's
just dating so you're going to date a
few of them simultaneously you're going
to see what they're made of you're going
to see how they respond to your
boundaries you're going to see how they
deal with the word no you know you're
going to see what they use their social
media for whether they use it to solicit
attention or if they're completely
private not even on social media you
know you're going to see how they deal
with
um you know I like you Becky but I don't
date women or I don't take women
seriously that go to Vegas for you know
weekends and girls nights out and you
know stuff like that so these are all
the things that you kind of have to put
yourself through because
that's that's what it takes to get into
an LTR really right
yeah no I agree one thing that I look
forward I know you mentioned this in
your book and you've talked a lot a lot
about it on your channel is you know the
the boss girl right the boss at work and
for whatever reason I don't know why but
I'm very much so attracted to that type
of woman someone that has our career
together someone who is in
um you know in a field like medicine
have you ever dated one of these boss
girls
uh about three months I dated one of
these boss women just got out of it I'm
actually
going on dates with another woman kind
of in the same field in the Midfield why
did it not work out what the boss girl
you did for three months yeah so
basically betaization
um she's one of the most intelligent
people in in their 20s I've ever met
um got beta ties tried to put my foot
down and she was an avidant so we went
her Separate Ways
yeah you're gonna get that man
um I get it like I was I was the same in
my 20s and I'll tell you now at my age I
don't want [__] you know when I come
home I don't want to deal with
you know I'm I'm cooler than you or I or
I can compete against you I'm not
dealing with that so it gets old after a
while like my ex-wife was a lawyer and I
dated a lot of really successful women
um you know around that time too like I
dated a professional opera singer I
dated accountants I dated dented like
people with professional designations
and it's always the same they they
want a strong virtuous man they want a
man that can lead they want a competent
guy they're generally looking for their
equal right but they also end up trying
to run you and I don't think they do it
intentionally
and not all of them will do this but a
lot of them do but
you know they try to run you you know
they try to tell you how to
do everything in your life and in your
household and that gets old pretty quick
and if you try to put your foot down a
lot of them don't like it so you're
going to find yourself churning through
a lot of these boss gals right
um so it's just a numbers game again I
mean if you're attracted to the boss
girl that's got her [__] together the
cool the cool thing about that there is
an advantage to it because if you
because if you get involved with a woman
and you decide to have kids with her and
she's got her life sorted you know she's
32 something like that like don't don't
wait till later on in life like if you
want to have kids do it do it with a
woman that's younger obviously you know
I've talked about this before but
if she's willing to enter your frame and
she's got her money sorted and she takes
a couple years off to have the the kids
she's probably not going to be that big
of an issue as far as dealing with your
assets if you have to untie the knot
because she's going to be making about
the same money as you I agree and that's
actually one of the things that I find
most attractive about dating someone
like that is that from the divorce
perspective right it's yeah but that's
not an attractive quality in women that
you're not going to get [__] when you
get divorced is it though like that's
not a truthful attractive quality that
most men find a women's like oh she's
you know she's got her life sword and
she's good looking and I probably won't
get [__] if I get divorced because we
make about the same money like that's
not what you're looking at like you're
not attracted to that you just like the
idea that it's a bit of a security
blanket if you have to untie the knot
right
no that's a good point
so just look man like at the end of the
day if you know you've you know if
you've had your fun you've been the
player like you've figured out what
women are about you know you know what
you will and won't tolerate it's again
it's just a numbers game you know for
guys it's just you know play the numbers
did a few women simultaneously let the
cream rise to the top and if you know
the cream Rises the top and she's like
Chase where do we stand you know we'll
be dating for a few months whatever I
don't want to share you you know
whatever their story happens to be at
that time then you at that time can make
the decision if you want to invite her
into your life and have a relationship
or potential kids with her or whatever
right where do you live you live in the
states yeah uh Southern us so luckily in
a place where there are women that are
looking for more long-term versus
short-term yeah opportunities yeah well
you know congratulations Chase I mean
you're at a good time in your life you
got your head squared away you're young
you've you know you know the you know
the content and it just seems like
you've got to
move to another stage of your life where
it's like LTR time and it's like look
dude
the thing with long-term relationships
is if you're going to abandon variety
and having other women in your life
she better be a compliment to your life
especially if if she's one of these
chicks that demands monogamy you know
from you make sure it's not a demand
that you're fulfilling make sure it's a
choice that you're making but at the
same time dude she better worship the
ground that you walk on if you're the
kind of guy that you say that you are in
the direction that you're going don't
take [__] from anybody
yeah no I agree I appreciate it rich all
right my man
thanks for hopping in man
um I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out